And highly intelligent in linguistics would be really good for poets, writers,
lawyers, politicians or speech writers. Because they're really good with spoken
and written words. Scientists, engineers and accountant would really benefit
from mathematical and logical intelligence. Because they're good at performing
mathematical operations and analyzing information and problems logically.
Spatial intelligence really helps navigators, pilots, architects and sculptors
do their job. Because they're really good at solving problems in three
dimensional space. Musical intelligent benefits musicians, songwriters, and
dancers. Because they have a greater capacity to perform, or compose music, and
to hear patterns and recognize them in music. Bodily-kinesthetic intelligence
really helps athletes, dancers, mechanics, and carpenters. Because the use
their whole body or different parts of their bodies to solve problems and make
something or carry out performances. You'll see high levels of interpersonal
intelligence in people who live contemplative lives, such as rabbis, priests,
or monks, because they reflect inwards. They really understand who they are,
and what they want. You'll see high levels of interpersonal intelligence in
psychologists, politicians, and some types of writers because they understand
other people and what motivates them. And finally, the naturalist intelligence
is great for botanists, ecologists, and biologists because they're sensitive to
the natural world, and can understand how to differentiate different living
things.